this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by hellofresh more on that later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
Ryan Sickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here at studio night pants doing it
night pants nation what's up y'all Ryan
Sickler very excited to be here with you
this week Ryan Sickler calm is the
website make sure you sign up for my
email list there and make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com slash our Sickler you'll get
video there every Tuesday of all the
episodes and now we're including time
codes in the list so you can go down and
see like one of your favorite stories
you can go right to the time code for
trying to make things easy for everybody
and also I want to make sure you
subscribe to the patreon subscribe I
want to hear your stories we got it
rolling now few episodes in it's been a
lot of fun I want to know your story
what's your story subscribe and there's
a link at the end of this episode you
can go right to that obviously
everything on Ryan Sickler calm and on
you do podcast calm and submit your
story to one email only everybody keep
hyah
just honey new podcast at gmail.com
that's where you submit your story we'll
go through it and hopefully get you guys
on you can do an episode with us make
sure you sign up over there too for the
Facebook fan page all that stuff and I
have to just think I mean it's
ridiculous you guys are the best [ __ ]
fans the support for night pants nation
is ridiculous they had they told me that
the manufacturer ran out of that pattern
in two sizes because they were not
expecting that big of a sale so they're
all coming you guys and you know we
record these at different times so night
shorts I don't know when this one's
gonna go up but they're either coming or
they're here so always check honey-do
podcast comm and you'll see all the
merch there Ryan Sickler calm all that
[ __ ] as I say every week too we record
here at the Santa Monica Music Center so
if you're looking for lessons especially
online lessons this is the spot go to
Santa Monica music calm use the code
honeydew and they'll waive the
registration fee and they'll give you a
free lesson when you sign up for a
package as you know I like to highlight
the lowlights and over here we like to
hear the stories behind the storytellers
and today's guest is no stranger to the
do and as a pleasure to have him back
here ladies and gentlemen please welcome
back
Josh Potter oh [ __ ] you did good that
four-time honeydew Machamp
I I'm gonna say this again you are
you're my first video episode ever like
crazy at ymh crab feast was all audio
but you're my first why mage video and
ever so I had a nice low visual bar to
set isn't it everyone else is pretty
here from there on out dude thank you
for being back thank you for coming to
the new studio thanks for having me all
right Thank You Man
go ahead plug it up I know there's no
show as well yeah we got no I mean I got
shows in September and November they're
on my Twitter at Josh under at Jay
underscore Potter on Twitter if they
still happen those are on sale but in
the meantime you can you can watch me
play fake football on Twitch twitch.tv
slash Josh underscore Potter it's how
I'm making a living right now just fake
owning the Buffalo Bills it's a it's a
bright future if my my reality becomes
true but yeah that's how I'm doing it in
cameo also cameo comm slash Josh
underscore Potter if you want to take
part in my adult sex work that's my life
now that's how I'm making a living is
shoulder hair porn and video games
shoulder hair poor yeah my family's
proud everyone's so proud of me what
I've become in the quarantine well
that's we were just talking about before
like our gosh our grandparents went
through a Great Depression you know all
that and what they must have been doing
during it's like I don't know in my mind
they're shoveling coal with who knows
what my granny used to save like as PTSD
like when she was old she would save
rubber bands she'd be like you never
know what you do with the [ __ ] rubber
band took down nine Nazis is what
issues in our pocket she'd take out be
like this is from 97 in still you you
know what I'm saying like [ __ ] I
can't even imagine now he's looking down
on heaven on me and just like what the
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying is this
many [ __ ] grandson sometimes I wish
she was still alive so I could see what
he would have to not only say about the
world but like what I've done with my
life you're like listen Ed you're real
you would have never made it back then
I'll be honest I wouldn't know I
wouldn't have either
I wouldn't know he was in World War two
he was a firefighter he was an
electrician and Here I am doing shoulder
hair pick ups and pick up some [ __ ]
weight say his resume again he fixed
airplanes in World War two he's a
firefighter an electrician and you have
to have like a steel set that's gonna
set this guy's fixing airplanes got
we're in position I'm like hey everyone
oh you wanna rub your dick in my
shoulder here fifty bucks
he's just lookin down in dude ah there's
so many moments I've recently thought
about him like looking down like
recently I had my room clean I know
don't know if you saw that I saw it and
you know that was hell in itself
obviously just going through that and
like facing that and knowing that
hundreds of thousands of people are they
Hell in a Cell well that's a better word
for it
I said Hell in itself but Christina and
Tom were nice enough to buy me like
furniture to put in my room and I I got
one of the dressers and you know now
they expect everyone so nice it's it is
so ridiculous though I can't thank them
enough
I mean they're like here's they're
turning me into a human being which is
more than my family's ever done for me
so grandfather's like at least thank God
for those two well and then so the
[ __ ] dresser comes right and it's in
a you know a flat box and they
expect everyone to be a goddamn
construction worker now you're [ __ ]
architect and you got a build for I wish
the furniture just came and then you
just put it in like the oil you can do
that you got to pay extra for I'll pay
whatever somebody guys like your
grandfather exact are putting it
together whatever in it I opened it up
and I'm looking at this thing and I'm
like I don't know how to [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] so my friend who's a comic and also
an adult film actress Kate Kennedy she
came over and like basically put my
dresser together for me she did that for
you yeah because she loves that [ __ ]
she's like don't you ever play with
Legos I was about to say its adult Lego
never [ __ ] I mean when I [ __ ] with
Legos I would put them all in one bin
and I'd build what I want I wouldn't
follow the directions so when I see a
directions I shut down so she built that
I mean like in something in my grandpa's
up there's like you got to have a
[ __ ] woman come over a woman come
over just your dresser you pieces and
I'm like so I'm sitting there going like
I'm possessive I'll be over you're doing
my cameo
I got a few cameos I got a couple
customs I got a put out there guys like
middle one firefight just one call yeah
he's going on a bunch of them and then
go on and [ __ ] wish it they could
electrocute a movie yeah I'm pulling
over when they come by like whoa oh my
god and I hear a siren I get scared I'm
like it's gone okay you're a siren in
the distance I'm like wow that's scary
oh my god dude it's so wide I mean I've
had it - were like back when I drove I
remember like I'd get a flat tire and
I'd have to call triple-a and like I
remember one time like a a real petite
like cheerleader girl like was the
triple a person and I was like uh do you
need help and she's like no you know
what I mean this is what I and I felt so
weird and again I could feel his just
his beaming down on me from heaven
shaking his head at me his friends are
giving him [ __ ] like what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] your grandson he's up there like
he was such like a man it's so weird
that I'm like only one generation
removed from him you know like I
remember my grandma she had I'm more
like my grandma than my grandpa viously
she would have like night terrors and
like mental health problems you know
she'd be like in the middle of the night
she used to just start screaming or like
yelling it's like terrifying to hear
Jill yeah she would or she would just
start talking loudly she'd be like oh I
was out the store and then you're like
oh my god and there would be like times
when I have to like babysit her cuz
she'd ever surgery is not I remember one
time she's yelling she's not scream dude
she'd be like oh you just feel like
there was one time I was babysitting her
cuz like cuz he doesn't wake up he
doesn't even affect it so he couldn't
like watch her when she had a surgery
she like broke her wrist or something
and I remember she had to like sleep a
certain way so my parents like set up a
cot and made me like monitor her at
night and I'd be like laying there dead
asleep and she'd be like oh we got would
be terrified like up like immediately
and then I hear my grandpa from the
other room go read oh shut up she could
just wake up that and go back to sleep
but he'd feel unfazed like it's nothing
like it's [ __ ] like the alarm clock
went off or something and he hit the
snooze it's probably seen Hitler person
yeah dude I remember we went camping one
time mm-hmm and I uh I'm blazing through
my list what you want with your
grandfather well we all we all used to
go to my aunt Gene's cottage where as
like up in the Allegheny Mountains
somewhere I don't
exactly where cuz we didn't go after I
was a little kid any longer but um you
know I had a creak and it had like you
know a big cottage and yard and stuff
and the whole family would go like
dozens of whose okay so like Anselm's
cuz every ball at the same time yeah and
my I lived with my grandparents like my
whole life like they lived in the
upstairs apartment we lived in the
downstairs apartment so they use your
dad or very close mom's parents and so
you know we're camping we're going I'm
getting firewood for the fire you know
in the Sun setting and there's this like
um it's like a cylinder sticking out of
the ground it's red and it's got a
little like metal top on it and I'm a
kid or whatever I just go and like jump
on it cuz it's like sitting there and
you know like you're a kid you jump on a
curb or you jump on something there was
no rhyme or reason why I did it but I
jump on it and I fall in the thing is
like a lid and it tilts like this and I
fall in and it's a well you felt like
baby just like baby baby so yeah I was
eight so like I didn't fall very far but
I felt you know ten feet down or
something like that so that's a far fall
friend it's a basketball well I got
wedged and it is at the bottom of it and
there was no walking flew so hold on you
fell in this one thing and you're wedged
in and you can see above you yeah or the
plane closed oh [ __ ] it was like I'm
screaming are you by yourself no
thankfully my sister saw me fall into it
so she runs and goes and gets my my
grandpa who's like down at the creek or
whatever and I didn't know what it was I
fell into him like there was no water in
it and it got like narrower as I went
down so I got kind of like stuck and
then my grandpa just opens the lid and
he's like what are you walking on this
thing for the first thing he says like
are you okay yeah yeah it's like so I
thought he said somebody's like I guess
I guess the lid wasn't locked and I was
sitting there like yeah I don't know
what he's like he starts just lowering a
rope down and I I just grab it and he's
like well and I'm like what and I
thought he was gonna pull me out lineman
yeah you think start pulling yourself
out right yeah
hell my newbie some help but over god
babe so he's helping me but he's like
you got to pull yourself out here a
little bit I can't pull you up 10 feet
I'm a [ __ ] old man oh my god you felt
a [ __ ] way it was it it was scary and
then like I got out of it and I was just
kind of like I was only down there for a
few minutes
and uh you know I had to wait for my
grandpa to go get the rope from his
truck that was probably the longest you
probably probably Walton yeah he's like
listen I've been in a tight spot he's in
a rush
yeah he's getting brush he's like
looking for the right rope I don't want
this rope on him right now is what gets
way what if I lose it down there oh yeah
yeah he was a [ __ ] man that's for
sure just they're totally removed from
you so just sit on the porch and whistle
you know like to himself yeah I just
whistle just like aimlessly just stare
into the space I'm telling you that's
it's where I'm headed it's all I want I
want I just want I don't care about the
size of the house I'd rather have more
land than a big house
yeah I'm fine in a regular-sized house I
just want to be left the [ __ ] alone how
many hours even can minutes even can you
sit on a porch just - whistling without
looking at your phone that's the thing
that you never have powers up there
looking at us right now like how could
these [ __ ] it is I remember he had to
get a cell phone at the tail-end
I forget what just a hat you know like
for whatever reason and he'd never
turned he wouldn't have it on he would
just be have it off like what are you
carrying it for you all told me I have
exactly he would turn it on to use it
yeah and then turn it on I was no
incoming just outgoing holy he'd be like
no you got to keep it on he's like keep
it on for what it's like I don't know
what this thing's doing to me he's
probably right about this yeah for sure
dude but yeah it was wild you know being
like thinking about all the race stuff
going on - like he was he was definitely
racist but like in an innocent way if
that makes sense you know like I don't
know that he was hateful but he
definitely used birds yeah exactly yeah
and you know like being in a world war -
I mean Jabez Jay
you know throwing that around like it's
[ __ ] you know hey what's up I had a
friend of mine who worked at a nursery
of landscaping not baby's nursery and uh
it would be a different story would you
hear it if it was a baby nursery he was
working with this guy and he was selling
they had a Japanese maple tree and the
abbreviation on the tag just for
barcodes and [ __ ] said Jack maple and
he's like well you have we have these
Jack maples here guy goes hey man Jesus
Christ okay this isn't your
grandfather's country and he was like
let's just read what the realize it was
short food Japanese whoops I got so mad
out of he's like I'm just reading the
abbreviated thing on the tag here for ya
man I don't know um but yeah I mean he
was a [ __ ] man dude and now I'm
playing video games every day and
putting pickups on [ __ ] for hundreds
of thousands of people I wonder what he
thinks so so I wish I could date you
know figure that out if there's people
up there yeah like you gotta come see
what your grads loves doing it's got
it's got those two cups on again again
how old's you now 34 he's 34 - how would
you do at 34 he's like I had four kids I
[ __ ] him and I built a failure yeah
yeah fought a war yeah but he's got he's
got kids now right nope no he but go
[Applause]
he can't even come oh my god could you
imagine he knew tell me my grandkids
can't even ejaculate and a woman
no can't ejaculate at all that's right
yeah that's true
oh man that is a [ __ ] classic dude
yeah man the pickup thing is uh yeah you
text I'm worried what is he got you got
recognized I did yeah I was I was
walking down the street and I uh usually
have my headphones in in this case I
didn't and I hear from the distance in a
car as it's like driving by a go tick
cops do a little wave thanks guys now
he's getting recognized by people for it
stranger well my parents are still alive
I wonder if they're getting any reaction
my mom has no idea what I do she has no
like she doesn't even bother checking in
it's not that she hasn't it's not that
she doesn't check in she doesn't
understand it this is so she went I'm
not judging no no it's probably best no
of course I'm not gonna educate her on
like how to watch it or anything but she
hasn't she sinks I'm still doing radio
still she thinks it's like radio still
you know she's like which channels it on
I'm like it's on the Internet she's like
but it's rate I'm like yeah whatever so
she doesn't know how to find it or
anything like that but I'd imagine what
if people went up to her and was like
your son's two cups right she's like
what what yeah I kind of hope that
happens actually
well I remember because we did the
episode of ymh you were on before me and
I was it I was out in the lobby watching
you with the tick comes up again so yeah
putting them back on do a higher-grade
to come pick up let's take a break and
tell you about our sponsor hellofresh
I had a chance to try hellofresh it is
hands-down my favorite meal kit delivery
service you can get fresh pre-measured
ingredients mouth-watering seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
with hellofresh they are America's
number one
miel kit hellofresh lets you skip those
trips of the grocery store and it makes
home cooking fun easy and affordable
their recipes are so delicious they
offer so many recipes to choose from
each week to help you break out of your
recipe rut there's something for
everyone including low-calorie
vegetarian and family friendly recipes
every week they're flexible they fit
your lifestyle you can keep your fridge
stocked by adding extra proteins or
sides like garlic bread your weekly
order you can easily change your
delivery days or your food preferences
and skip a week whenever you need so
feeding the whole family is super easy
with larger box sizes for more servings
and more savings you save time and
stress effortlessly hellofresh offers
contactless delivery to your doorstep
for easy home cooking with the family
you're gonna love it
I I was cooking with my daughter she's
almost six we're sitting there putting
these meals together the family friendly
one is honestly for picky eaters that's
the way it was explained so I got the
meat one now and she's sitting there
cooking with me helping me out prep and
everything I'm gonna try the family one
next time so she can you know have a
little more options as well so go to
hello fresh comm slash honey dew 80 and
use code honeydew 80 to get a total of
80 dollars off including free shipping
on your first box that's hellofresh comm
slash honeydew eighty and use that code
honeydew eighty to get a total of $80
off free shipping in your first box
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh com for more details
now let's get back to the show I've been
doing that ship for ever though I got
into that trap and radio I found where I
was you don't mean I didn't come to
break well just in general ants yeah
yeah I mean I did the first thing that
got me on the radio was getting shot
with a Taser what do you men I had a
police officer just shoot me with a
Taser in the studio because at first he
was gonna just give everyone a little
stun gun and we're like but he's like
but if you want I could shoot it into
the back of someone with the prongs and
everything do the full ride the 5a
lightning and none of them wanted to do
that is it 5 5 seconds yeah and how did
he do standing when he did it yes so
like
I just tell you real quick my cousin's
what at this point he's retired he's
he's been a retired cop forever long
story short day one day one when he
finally out of training and [ __ ] he's
riding with his partner and some
high-speed chase happened so they get
involved they hit a median in a roll man
he has to get his leg breaks he's got to
get pins and all this [ __ ] put in it and
they give him an office job for a couple
years and like in by the way now you can
retire with full benefits and I was like
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
[ __ ] was a cop one day it's on
the fourth day eventually but then
worked for you know but he couldn't but
he's a liability on the street yeah you
know he can't run after people and [ __ ]
so anyway
he told me that when they went through
training they used to tase guys standing
up with it they would freeze up and
they'd fall break their jaw or their
nose so he started making them get on
their knees yeah
so the fall was shorter that's why well
the way that they did it for me well
first of all none of the show hosts or
anyone on the show wanted to do it yeah
so I'm sitting there as an intern and I
was like I'll [ __ ] do it you
volunteered you didn't get volunteer
nope by Valentin to get on the air and I
was young and so they're like alright so
they had it so two people held my arms
and then they're slowly lowered me to
the ground and so and that's the other
thing that blew me away it doesn't
conduct through someone else yeah when
they talk yeah cuz we used to when we
were kids I'm sorry I keep it or no
that's a nice is what trips me out we
were kids we used to have this farm that
was not far away and it had an electric
fence and if you grab that mullah have
you ever touched one right right and
then if they grabbed you as long as you
grab someone else it goes conducts right
through you right I wonder why what is
it I don't know no idea let's just
through those a lot of scientists maybe
it's less well I don't know but it's um
these [ __ ] needles are like little
harpoons but they just go into your what
you feel is that painful - yeah and then
they take them out and they have to be
like you know it's like a hook because
they leave that [ __ ] so you don't can't
run away you know what I mean yeah and
they can keep it going to that that's
what they said to me while it was in me
they're like you want to do another one
like no no and I would like took him out
of me finally but Tom what's that feel
like do you just it felt like I got
struck by lightning but I the thing that
got me on the radio is I didn't swear
cuz if I would a curse they would have
had to dump out of it it would have gone
gone away forever and so I didn't swear
they thought I was a pro so then you
know where oh it's like what is he gonna
do next kind of thing grandfather would
have been proud of that doggone he was
alive during that part and I remember he
started hearing that I was on the radio
and he used to brag about it or
something someone told me that that was
nice to hear but I don't know that he
exactly heard what I was doing because I
was also then like wearing dresses and
going
I went trick or the right high dude I
was wearing uh I wore a schoolgirl
outfit and went trick-or-treating at
pedophiles houses I swear that's a stunt
thing how'd you do Jesus Christ on the
internet somewhere and then now it's
great we did I did this was a contest I
helped come up with called nude with a
dude and it worked the first time I know
you had Tommy Lee and here was for
Motley Crue tickets and we were all
right yeah we had two guys that we said
whoever can last in this sleeping bag
the longest two guys to get together
naked whoever could last the longest get
the tickets
so we'd have them rotate and stuff we do
little bits like a come in every 15
minutes and put porn in front of them so
you know then it'd be like alright you
got to go back to front now you got to
go front to front
ah you would make them rotate like that
in a sleeping bag in a sleeping bag
strangers yeah yeah
what would you cuz I would never do that
for motley crew Freddie [ __ ] tickets
what would you what would it take you it
would have to be a substantial it's not
unfortunately for me it took my salary
and my job listen because your contest
was such a hit that we did it again and
only one person showed up so they were
like you know we need it we need an
eight o'clock you know so they're like
you got I and I was like I guess I'm
taking the bullet because it was like
you know figured it was on it was on me
to have this segment full and if that
guy that contest think off that's an
empty slot so I was like I'll go the guy
was that one for
for probably another Cosimo Teleca maybe
or something and I told the guy like yo
let's go back for a second so how long
does who how long did they last before
Sam I won the first time it was awesome
it went like it took two it got to the
point where it was like the end of the
show and the guy Long's I like to three
hours well we started it at around like
a little before 8:00 that shows four
hours and so it went till 10:00 and it
was getting to the end of the show and
we're like what do you guys got to step
it up here and so the one guy just
started beating off no and that's how he
got the other guy to go all right
because he was like they were like I die
he's like in the sleeping bag so and I
was like to shake it you should did that
probably an hour ago I'm glad you wait
in a way I'm glad you waited so we could
have that TSL baby time spent listening
so when it comes up again and we only
have one person show up I go I gotta
take the [ __ ] bullet I told the guy
I'm like you're gonna win just make me
just get me past the 8:30 break you know
what I'm saying like I'll get out I'll
give up or whatever so I had to do nude
with a dude I didn't get any new money I
was getting paid dog [ __ ] like minimum
wage are you still an intern at this
point have you been oh no I'm hired but
I'm getting paid nothing like I got paid
nothing throughout my entire I did a lot
of things for no money for radio and now
it's you know Here I am bringing that
expertise to the couch off your mom's
house and putting tit cups on my body
that's child's play compared to what I
did in the radio game but I was a young
buck back then you know what man's you
get in this thing with this dude what
yeah oh just do it he's he looked like a
um does he he looks kind of like I look
now actually he's got like a long
squirrely hair he looked like the
sidekick and remember in Ninja Turtles
the one dude who was like he had like
that flat brim had he look kind of like
the Undertaker I don't know why he's
coming to mind but he had like he was
real mousy and like real like a man you
know that kind of guy and he wasn't like
it wasn't like six five three honorbound
no I wasn't crazy we both fit in there
pretty snug
and you know we did the whole like you
know how long were you in there for the
a probably 45 minutes you've been there
for 45 minute and it's it's something I
gotta tell you like I remember the one
host of the show shred was like you know
in a queer in a commercial break at this
point and now I have time like alright
man I'm gonna get out of the sleeping
bag so if you want to turn around or
whatever I'm put my pants on it's just a
weird like walk of shame to put your
pants back on in the radio studio
emanating out of us yeah and then you go
do your were naked with a dude yeah you
go over there email them there you got
yeah then you get your clipboard out
you're like alright well we got an
interview yeah that interview at 10:45
you want me to get you the prep you know
like you have to go right back into work
mode after that I've looked Cheryl in
the office how are you I interned at
radioing in college and I was the total
opposite of you I didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah they would give me [ __ ] i intern
for this station it was uh at the time
was 100gr X and was classic rock and
then it went to 100x right when I got
there and that's when it went to the 90s
like bush and Candlebox and that kind of
rock and at the time all that and they
were big all right we're gonna go see
we're going to this Candlebox concert
tonight yeah and you have to hand out
all there's a picture of me somewhere
with the Bandar candle box out there it
exists somewhere on the throat for me
laugh and they were like you gotta give
these bumper stickers out and [ __ ] and
then you have the credentials coming
through the back you can watch the show
or whatever and I would go okay and then
they would leave and I'd wait five
minutes I'd go over to a dumpster I
throw every bumper sticker right in the
[ __ ] dumpster and then I would come
through the front door and stay out and
then I'd eventually be like like you got
rid of them I'm like yep I got rid of
them I used to out of just pure love of
the game used to go to competing radio
station events and put bumper stickers
like not like you know not the sticker
on the car but I'd put them in the
windshield of like every car in the
parking lot of them just like to be that
kid or whatever and be like see I love
it here you know you're gonna give me a
real job someday right and then they're
like no we're gonna keep taking
advantage of you
while you keep doing this [ __ ] yeah
exactly so I was like I said I was a
young kid so I was hungry or whatever
well they asked me to get into this is
where it ended for me this is this is
how crazy they got and I was like I
ain't doing this so at the end of the
year they again switched to a froggy
country there were these froggy FM
countries around the the US like a thing
they kept copying over and over again
yeah and I had already gotten my credits
that I meet and everything so I was just
done yeah
and I'm just about and they're like hey
so we've got this event today you're
gonna be and it's like summer it's hot
as [ __ ] yeah you're gonna be we need you
to dress up in this froggy costume and
and I was like nope they're like what do
you mean no I was like I'm done my
internships done I'm this is free I got
my credits it's a rat like no no no you
can't I go oh yeah and I just hung up I
won't get into froggy [ __ ] suit it's
weird when you do the line on stuff like
that I wouldn't get into suits like that
but I would be like let's do this by
myself
yeah exactly like at least I'm seen on
the one you know what I mean like that's
where I would draw the line I [ __ ] I
swam with a snapping turtle
I'll get it bite you it it did a little
bit dude this bastion like I know it
could have taken my [ __ ] arm off yeah
easily and I didn't know that we didn't
know enough about snapping turtles until
after we like it's a virus or like
whatever we were like I was like on the
way home in which and guy calls me from
the office he's like doing a little
google in here ah nice yeah yeah yeah
he's like you're lucky you got out it
because and like he goes if it would
have latched on you and we would have
chopped its head off it's still would
have been latched on to you he's like
they they like stay on it he's like I
don't know how we would have gotten it
up we would have had to like take you to
somewhere to like get it off you cuz
it's like if it clamps on and you chop
its head off it does not stop land stays
the job I think it like lasts like ten
years or so I don't know holy
they're monsters you could ride some of
those things get huge this thing was the
size of like a garbage can lid yeah
Michelle yeah and it [ __ ] like to
handhold you have to hold it like this
yeah yeah dude and it just didn't it bit
you where it didn't get me like it just
was like it got near me and I was like
that wasn't enough and it like scraped
me where were you were you know it was
in the guy's pond that he told us he had
him so like we just went there and the
guy I told the guy he had a gun I told
the guy no matter what happens fire that
gun it'll sound awesome on the radio
even if the turtle hasn't come near me
just pretend you know so when I go holy
[ __ ] it almost bit me he starts to fire
it was that close to me so I'm by the
air and I'm like oh [ __ ] it just like
almost got me there and the guy just
Gugu she and they're like what the [ __ ]
was I like yeah I think your gun fire
they're like what the and I knew it
would sound cool but they were like uh
and then they just hunt like the guy
just like put me on hold like Reagan
like just put me on hold he was like
shooting guns I'm not gonna keep him on
the air so like it was a it was an
interesting moment but dumb yeah I did
all kinds of dumb [ __ ] like that and
here we are today using it to my
advantage for the plenty of people I'm
gonna put my dick in a dick cage next
you're gonna do that well Christina
bought it so I think I have how we were
talking about it on that episode and I
was like kinda you know yeah I what is
the whole point is to punish you so that
you don't get arrested to do well it's
like you put your soft dick in it and
then it tortures you by like then if you
you know they do things to you I I think
this is what happens in the BDSM world
it's so that if you get an erection
obviously it hurts because it's in a
[ __ ] cage yeah and so you're supposed
to not get one despite what they're
doing to you so I think that's the game
that's gonna be played is I'm gonna put
it on and then they're gonna get a woman
see if she can turn me on but I've I
don't think I'll be able to I don't
think I'll be able to get hard with all
those eyes on me
Tom and Christina there I don't think
I'll be able to get hard regardless of
what she could be like blowing me I
don't think I'm gonna get hard you know
what I mean I can't God you should have
a split screen of your grandfather and
heaven looking down on you doing that
yes Jesus you're only getting older kid
[Music]
so I don't know tom has a secret weapon
lady why's that he says he's gonna bring
in and we'll see secret weapon yeah I
can't wait to see this [ __ ] I'm glad it
doesn't have because I noticed some mods
of these cages have like a thing that
goes in your urethra yeah oh god I just
and I used my leg I prayed I like ask
Christine I'm like it's not the one with
the your wreath or a thing all right and
she's like I don't know and then I like
when look thank God it's not I mean
would you have done it if it was I don't
think so I don't think I could handle
that nothing's going up my dick hole no
I've already I had I think I told that
on this podcast before but I had a thing
in my urethra a scope for uh you know I
thought I had a blockage or something as
a little kid and they put a scope up
their camera and it [ __ ] hurt yeah
like a lot I still remember it vividly
and I was like five I worked with a girl
one time when I was writing back in the
day and and it's so funny cuz another
one of my friends recently we got
together a friend of ours passed from
cancer and we all got together to to
hang out and see one another and
celebrate him and she said we still in
communication but she's like I'll never
forget that one time so-and-so told you
about that dude and this guy that this
girl was dating was into it oh it's hard
to even say but he would have her grow
the pinkie coke nail oh yeah and then
dig it in his urethra put it up his
[ __ ] dick hole and then carve and I'm
while she's sitting around the school oh
my god she's like I just remember how
upset that major I'm like it's upsetting
me that you're bringing it up right now
like why are you I mean a man there's
people into whatever I'm not
judge and I'm just saying that ones I
can't that might be a good idea by the
way to do before the the dick cage
experiment is for me to do coke before
it because then I definitely won't get
hard watch you die on the god no all I
needs a few bumps and my dick will be
like peace out bro
my dick is like a couple bumps in my
dicks like well I'm retired forever I
feel like my dick I mean I don't know
what have you ever done cut your
grandfather's like I used to do coke
before I flew planes for cry still get
are every time ya know you've never done
cocaine no I'm not I'm I mean I've done
a few drugs I've talked about it's not
I've done shrooms a couple times I've
never [ __ ] with ass that I've never
[ __ ] with coke I've never [ __ ] with
as I pour my water
yeah coke isn't a thing that I like I
always say like I don't do coke but I'll
do it you know what I mean like it's
around so I've never like been it's not
like a penchant of mine because I don't
like upper things but right that's
exactly me on weed but you know I like
when girls have coke and they want to do
it I yeah I know where this is going so
I mean where wherever it goes or not I
I've dated tons of girls that do cocaine
I have done cocaine and from whatever
but the unfortunate part is I've gotten
older is I've noticed that when you do
it even minutely my [ __ ] dick is just
it couldn't be in a worse state well
then you're totally convincing me not to
ever no of course I that's what I said
I'm like if you would have gone to my
high school in dare program or whatever
anti-drug stuff if you would have just
said to me like you do coke your dicks
gonna look like the saddest thing you've
ever seen it's gonna be it's gonna crawl
up in your body it's gonna crawl up in
your pop you want to embarrass yourself
in front of a woman do coke and show her
your [ __ ] dick that's what they
should tell you in dare to keep you off
of it you think these this guy here and
this 2 cups of something yeah okay yeah
yeah I remember we had a I've told this
before a long time ago but we had a dare
officer come in you know and they passed
around this little trade his box it was
like what drugs look like in it and it
[ __ ] [ __ ] up and I had a extra
joint on it
that's hilarious cop got one back like
Amy this isn't an amnesty box I always
wondered if those things were real when
they brought him in either well what
they weren't the ones we got yeah we had
a guy I'll never forget this Maryland
state trooper told this story about I
mean I wonder if it was true cuz he
looked fine but he told the story about
how he was hit by a drunk driver and he
was so close to death that they told him
look we can't put you under or you won't
make it and we have to perform surgery
with no anesthesia is what he told us
and it was like peeling his face like
brutal [ __ ] you know what I mean and
we're like Jesus Christ they're coming
in they used to take a car from I mean
they would say it was a drunk driving
accident you don't know if it was but
any car that had been mangled yeah and
they would just throw it right on the
front of the high school lawn and they
would say this is what happens when you
drink and drive you know try to scare
kids that's creamy while kids are riding
by throwing beer bottle yeah that's
crazy yeah we never had anything like
that he was in the 90s it was a little
more sensitive I think you know we did
we didn't watch like red concrete or
whatever that video was where they'd
show that video of just like brutal car
accidents drunk driving car accidents
none of that none of that kind of [ __ ]
my mom used to tell us when we were
little kids really [ __ ] up stories
though about trying to like scare us
straight almost but she would get like I
feel like my mom got off on talking
about morbid [ __ ] you know because I
remember like her just telling us a
story like oh yeah Karen and her husband
were riding along the road and a deer
came out and just jumped who first
through the windshield and then it got
scared so it started flailing and it
smashed both their heads in and they
died and my mom were like six my were
like wow that's [ __ ] crazy
and my mom's just like nonchalantly
telling this story to us like at the
dinner table I'm like oh my god I'm like
it just painted this vivid image in my
brain that I've never just little been
able to shake just lately imagine like
everyone's kind of like you're in a car
accident with a deer jumping through the
windshield and then they're like you
kind of come too and then the deer comes
soon it's a car and then you just get
your [ __ ] head bashed in that's
[ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up yeah thanks mom use
your arms a snapping turtle though right
that's true I will again we didn't know
what other [ __ ] did you do do you
remember any other I mean that's crazy
yeah I mean now if I have to now here's
how badly I don't want to do that but if
I have a choice between nude with a dude
or snapping turtle I'm definitely
getting in a sleeping bag
no the snapping turtle is probably the
most dangerous you might as well get in
the water with a [ __ ] crocodile we
did not know the level of which we
thought you know it hurt if it bit me
like a [ __ ] turtle you know like but
the further reading that we did once the
bit was underway we did do it and I
remember like I remember riding out
there and having the radio on and
hearing them go like oh it says here
that they can really clamp on for a long
time and I'm like this looks like a
decade I'm sitting I'm like riding on
them like this is part of a little bit
you know like I'm asking like do you
think that's true and then yeah they uh
we came back and that could have been
bad
there was some I mean listeners
eventually I tried to like point the
contest I would come up with to the
listener because we would have listeners
do a bunch of dumb [ __ ] and got a legal
should you have in them so this is
what's amazing about it before a certain
point remember there was a contest in
Seattle where a woman died because she
like was drinking too much water no well
it was a contest that we used to do also
you know these Cantonese contests and
[ __ ] they get recycled and they're not
exactly you know brain surgeries so you
know you kind of retread some things we
used to do one called don't break the
seal where it would be like we'd get a
coffee sponsor to bring in a bunch of
coffee people would drink in the first
person to pee is out so the last person
wins the Seattle station did a contest
called we for
we and it was like when the Wiest gaming
system first came out and the last
person who didn't take a piss after
drinking water would win it and this
woman got water poisoning and he died I
don't even know that was a thing so she
know when told it's a little happen yeah
and drank so much she was so super
hydrated that apparently you can drink
straw much water and die yeah so she
died that put an end
nationwide to any listener contest
because we would have him come in and
signed this shitty little waiver but
they could have if they died that waiver
doesn't mean [ __ ] we said we had one
time mom this one was for Metallica
tickets I we used to do lick it for
tickets was like a common thing we'd
have people like toilets we'd have
people Oh urinal cake sweet so we we put
on this really ridiculous hot sauce on a
plate and like spread it out on a plate
and everyone had to clean their plate
and after we had to meet like doorknobs
toilets could you imagine in [ __ ]
coronavirus days yeah like so there we
had him lick off something and then the
toilet and then the hot sauce though was
the thing that they did it and these
people like we're like call 9-1-1 they
so we had to call like not ambulances
and [ __ ] and if all of us on the new
shows up and they're your grandfather's
roll it up like yeah [ __ ] are you doing
but it was great I mean like I was
scared we're all gonna get fired but
then it was like it was great because
then it got us on the news and [ __ ] and
like there's our hosts like in the lobby
going like yeah you know we had a
contest go a little awry you know that
kind of thing I remember one the
scariest one though that didn't come off
as scary on the air it just was scary
for me was we had guys do like almost
like a Polar Plunge it was you know the
middle of winter and it was like you
have to swim to this and back in some
part of the the river and I go like it's
just me out there with these guys and so
I'm thinking like all the sudden I see
the guy like struggling when he's at the
halfway point and he's like I don't know
if I can make it back and I'm like you
gotta
if I can't come out there and save you
and I'm the only one here you go yeah
and he just was like any mate I remember
him getting out of the water I mean
going like and I put took him back with
those it was for like bills verse
Vikings tickets in like 2006 you know
when the bills were [ __ ] like this
guy probably could have gotten like
hypothermia or died or whatever and I'm
thinking like good god man like I can't
believe I skated out of that one you
know who knows what it could have
happened if that guy just drowned out
there the [ __ ] people will do for nut
like when you really break it down if
you can step outside of her singer
alright if I were to die
what's a week off is my life $300 is my
life worth up what are the ticket sure
it was another time [ __ ] BEC [ __ ] yes
wasn't max team [ __ ] tickets bra just
for the tail yeah it's what that I don't
think that should exist anymore though I
mean not like I think if radio tried to
do [ __ ] like that I mean you can
probably barely get people to call in
doing what's radio yeah exactly so I
mean like I love that the conversation
is switching you used to be what's
podcast like a radio show no I need to
I'm like what's radio yeah yeah I
[ __ ] love it I mean I'm I still have
friends in the business and I know a lot
of them you know through this whole
coronavirus thing a lot of them
furloughed lost their jobs and because
radio is always looking for an excuse to
[ __ ] cut down and it's nice to work
in a in a the same type of medium kind
of and have it be expanding as opposed
to constantly reducing cuz that's what
would happen to me I'd get a new job or
a new job title heaped on me and I would
never get a raise and they would just
take the money from that job and keep it
for the corporation you know and
eventually I stopped even just trying
it's just I would show up when I want I
would leave when I want it got bad and
so thankfully I got to move out here
because it was coming to an end whether
they were gonna fire me or you were
gonna die I was just gonna kill myself
yeah so I you know I wasn't doing that
[ __ ] by the end either cuz I wasn't
worth it you know I thought I would lead
to glory and
you know a show and stuff and now and
that that window was closed you know
they weren't gonna make a new morning
show with me ever you know so yeah Here
I am babe why don't you come to the
podcast well I will be I was gonna say
you're so in the [ __ ] I mean even
going back to radio days you're so
embedded in it no for sure you know um
and I've done you are gonna be doing one
yeah oh it's great I don't know if I'm
supposed to talk about that or what but
I and I think it was just a matter of
figuring out what that's gonna be so can
you talk about it or not yet I mean I
don't know I don't think so
I can just say that I'm that it's in the
works you know so I don't know what it's
going to be quite yet either by I can't
wait to see what your grandfather things
I can't I mean I'm already there's
nothing else I guess I I mean when I
wake up every morning and I take off my
shirt to do my shoulder hair porn for a
few people I mean and God bless you for
book in the cameos you're saving my
bacon out there but it is a little piece
of me dies inside yeah each and every
one
well goes you mentioned Tom and
Christina having your place cleaned and
it really it [ __ ] with you a little
bit yeah why how what happened I mean it
didn't [ __ ] with me in terms of like I'm
glad I got it done and I made that step
cuz it was bad and it was like a prison
that I put myself in and I just couldn't
get over it and um telling us the L bro
yeah it was dog and so I [ __ ] once it
was cleaned I felt relief in that but
then you know showing it to people and
like knowing like showing the video of
it being cleaned well just showing how
bad it got to people was embarrassing
did you have people come over though no
never never you never had visitors never
once I mean not during that time right
when it was bad I had it before prior I
mean cuz I've even even some girls like
that have been in my place like hit me
up and they're like man it got bad
because they had been in in there before
and it was normal and I was like yeah
you know you know and just it was weird
like you know having because there were
some people that reached out and were
like super nice about it but then there
were some people who I definitely could
tell it turned like I no longer have any
sort of a thought
with them you know what I mean because
it's like if I say anything try to make
a statement on anything it's like what
the [ __ ] you know look at how shitty
your life you know what I'm saying
so there was like that element of it
that kind of [ __ ] with me a little bit
but you know the the outpouring of
positivity has been greater so you know
there's that but you know you you see
one comment you're like ah [ __ ] I mean
yes guy that's got nine followers and
yeah I don't and then like you know
through of positivity I was doing so
good at ignoring all that [ __ ] but
coronavirus like makes you just bored
and you're just looking at Twitter
constantly and I'll just read one more
yeah exactly one more I said no more
rude oh I shouldn't have read that that
one's gonna [ __ ] well now it does it's
like gambling and you're just down yes
and you're like I gotta put in another
bet try and get back up I don't know how
you feel like I try once a year I'm and
I'm not saying you're not or anything
I'm just telling you the type of person
I'm super clean any a national tell ya
i'm i like [ __ ] clean organized like i'm
a little bit OCD with that kind of stuff
but also once a year i'll try to go
through [ __ ] in my place and just get
rid of it yeah
like if i haven't used it don't need it
i'm like it's whatever it's gone you
know no that's and that's proact that's
the thing i'm but learning that i have
to deal with the reason that it's good
and I really believe this and I've seen
it happen is because once you physically
and literally move [ __ ] out of your
space you now open up space for new
things to come in you want those to be
obviously positive and good things but
of course you got to get rid of some
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know I'm not talking
about suits and stuff that you might
wear once or two times a year of course
but I mean you know I just I've had a
tent in my [ __ ] storage it's moved
with me since 1919 like 90 [ __ ] 7 I
just gave it to a friend of mine so she
and her daughter can [ __ ] happen I'm
like you might want to air it out but
it's money I've never had with it every
time I've moved I've shed so when I
moved here I came here with two
suitcases that's it and I still I mean
now I've got furniture some furniture
and stuff like that but I was never
messy in like like my kitchens clean
[ __ ] living rooms clean like cuz I
share those with a roommate so it's like
I'm never messy in public areas yeah
it's just when then when I would like go
into my own [ __ ] it would be like that's
where I would just like a let it go you
know and it was it's just weird how it
accumulated I didn't even notice it
until it was like really bad and then I
was like talking to dr. Drew about I'm
like yeah I think I'm like a hoarder
maybe I don't know am i I'm like I'm not
like I don't have things but I
definitely like I'm too depressed to
clean my room you know so yeah it was a
relief and now I just have a person come
over every other weekend yeah clean it
it's once I could get through that first
step it's easy now you know what I'm
saying like to maintain yeah it's easy
to stay on top of [ __ ] now we'll get
once it gets a little too far out boom
you know what like once a month maybe
actually even low longer for a woman to
come do it or a man someone I should I
don't know I ought to say it is late
yeah it's my place but yeah I know I
mean I heard somebody I'm like every
other week you know it's a couple bucks
and it just gets out it keeps um keeps
it out of my brain you know what I mean
so I figure that's how I'll just keep
like there's little scuff marks on the
doors coming in from people move and
[ __ ] in and stuff and I see it I'm like
I'm like why yeah they try to let it go
like why it's not all camera Mia being
blind is missing reference I really
don't see those things I said that to
draw like you know what happens when I
when I see the mess I go where smell it
evade a problem that's like ever you
know I've never seen like a spider in
the shower or anything like that and I
always hear stories about that like oh
my god a spider in the shower and stuff
and I'm just like I'm blessed with the
taking off my eyes every day when I go
in the shower so I never see any of that
I never see like I remember I went to
meet a girl at like a hotel and there
was a roach in it and she was like so
freaked out I was like I would have
never seen that [ __ ] roach if you
didn't point it out are you talking
about our pcs oh yeah I went in any of
those nothing fans were pointed till the
HD camera I'm like oh man there were
just bugs crawling around the whole time
weird didn't pick up on that I knew it
was bad
but I didn't know it was that bad so the
day ever
well I was gonna ask you if they ever
replaced you at the radio station with
another you know they did but a little
gay but then the [ __ ] started to go away
cuz all the people started [ __ ] up so
much they did give somebody my gig but I
don't know how much of the same stuff
he's doing or whatever I mean by the end
I was doing a lot of different kind of
things so I don't know what they gave
him or whatever I'm sure they didn't
even pay him as much as they were paying
me you know they loved to [ __ ] everyone
over so my buddy today he's been at the
same station running the same station
for 15 years in Des Moines and he just
got let go like in three sentences in an
email it's crazy just [ __ ] heartless
afternoon 15 year after putting his
heart and soul in this [ __ ] place for
15 years it's mine it's one of the
things I dislike the least about our our
businesses morning radio I know it used
to be huge and I I mean but getting up
at [ __ ] 4:30 or 5:00 o'clock to go
talk to some people that do that [ __ ]
regularly and try to be funny and
energetic and all that and they're
always in a small little closet and some
a weird office building and you're
walking the hallways nurse nine other
stations going on in there at the same
[ __ ] time
yep yeah it's being on the other side of
that and then doing comedy and like I
remember when Tom came in and did our
show like twice he did it that's how you
met the first time I don't that's I met
Tom doing a weekend with him at helium
but then you know every time I'd work a
weekend
the headliner would wake up the next day
come do morning radio be all tired I'd
have been there for three hours like hey
how you doing you want any walk coffee
you know like that's there like what do
you what are you doing here so yeah I
did he did come in and I have a there's
like if you go to like the bottom of my
Instagram to like two thousand thirteen
or something I used to take a picture of
every comic that would come in and post
ever ever and there's like a picture of
Tom just standing there you could tell
he like does not want nobody nobody did
yeah and I'm and I used to like our show
was great because we understood that and
we try to make you know everyone
comfortable or whatever but now I go in
and do morning radio and it's like the
opposite I'm like
[ __ ] wait to see what hacks are up in
this you I bet for you yes like for me
I'm like so I once heard I want to say
it was Doug Benson that I might have
that wrong but who asked his audience
one night how many people were here
because you heard me on the radio and no
one raised their hands and he was like
well [ __ ] it and we're done with that
yeah are we doing that for and I did I
won't say the venue but I did a show not
too long ago and I asked the same
question and it was one lady who brought
her husband and I was like what are we
doing yeah getting up at [ __ ] five
o'clock in the morning we're all
spending our time and effort to get to
some of the depends on the show to like
they'll put you on a show that doesn't
even make sense it's like you know the
people that are listening to this don't
want to hear what I have to say you know
what I mean so some of them do make
sense like we were a comedy show it made
sense to have the topic of Kevin and be
but even yeah that's exactly that's
exactly what friend Reagan was and so I
think you've done it actually and you
know they would take it by phone to if
the guys didn't want but I think I did
when I was doing my album I might have
done a phoner for them yeah well I
totally did yeah yeah he talked about
you yeah of course uh so you know we
were we would recognize that and plus
you know I was a comic also so I knew
these people
but here's the thing I'm down to do a
phoner sure at my you know whenever I
can then play it whenever the [ __ ] you
want play to 5:30 we would tape them we
would tape a bunch of phone like that's
eventually what it ended up becoming and
that got boring to be honest to like
just I know you taped interviews in the
afternoon and then the next day you're
just showing up to like run a tape you
know what I mean and then you're just
sitting there while it plays so you know
it's just a weird I loved doing it so
much when I first started and then it
just jaded me like you wouldn't believe
dude and he dug me into the ground and I
was like I thought I was I was done like
I'm like I'm 31 years old at this point
and I'm it's not like things are getting
better they're only getting worse and
then thankfully I got to come out here
and do this so right at that moment it
was like a parachute you know opening up
finally so that's the thing I love about
comedy too is you know after all these
years I'm still not Jade
by I'm Angie you know a little bit of
course but not jaded enough to not to
hate it not want to do no I don't get
jaded humming in you know though I'm
always catching new [ __ ] online now and
I'm like oh [ __ ] that dude is funny that
lady's funny there's no that's exactly
true and like the thing about radio that
makes you jaded is just the corporate
structure of it that beats you down and
makes you not feel any sort of value you
know that in comedy it doesn't exist you
get the value out of what you do so it's
completely different and that's what I
was doing I was doing comedy and radio
and the radio was suffering because I
was out every night or on the road on
the weekends and then coming back and
just mailing it in essentially because I
just didn't I never even when I was
doing my best or hardest I wasn't
getting any rewards from that where he
got all for the morning radio gig now
would you take it
[ __ ] no [ __ ] no unless it was like a
like crazy amount of money which it
would never be you know what I mean I
don't even think they give out
six-figure salaries anymore I was going
to say not for a terrestrial radio not
unless it's massively syndicated I mean
or you're Nick Cannon or something and
you're doing that [ __ ] but yeah I mean
like [ __ ] Kevin and beam just got
fired out of the begin T whatever they
put on in that spot it's gonna be first
cheapest [ __ ] yeah you know and it'll be
[ __ ] and I'll put the guy I'll
probably have nine jobs it'd probably
also be like the more the music director
the [ __ ] the introduction director
you know what I mean so yeah dude I
remember when I first came here to
someone was like why don't you try to
get a radio job just to like bridge the
gap or whatever and I was like they're
not even gonna hire me I would get a job
as a production director and I would
make minimum wage probably to like a run
an entire clusters worth of commercials
do you know what I'm saying it's like
not worth the squeeze you know might as
well go get a job at the [ __ ] you
know what's all civil service test or
some [ __ ] it's a very telling decision
because as we all know this [ __ ]
business comedy is there's no stability
here and there's no it can be gone at
any moment for any reason yeah you know
all of it and don't look at the [ __ ]
virus yeah yeah that's right a pandemic
hits the world and there goes comedy and
that's not him
something any of us were ever [ __ ]
even their own into the equation of [ __ ]
so I'm thinking earthquakes were ruined
[ __ ] physically and literally before
a virus shuts us all [ __ ] oh like the
comedy store got crushed into major
earth and slide yeah that was more
realistic to me than a panda or some
Saudis bought it yeah yeah that was that
was way more realistic you know and then
boom the thing you think it's never
gonna happen happens so for you to take
the leap outta radio into comedy is very
telling about what my there was nowhere
to go there was nowhere to go I remember
when I came out here and I got an office
job I talked about on here that one time
where I didn't know what I was doing and
I remember being kind of relieved going
like hey I can still get a job in an
office holy [ __ ] I thought that was well
you know my resume is [ __ ] nude with
a dude and [ __ ] me like a place
didn't even win yeah I bet I could have
won if I was if I was really in the
contest and it wasn't a wink and a nod I
could have got him out of there I would
have started you know I would he use the
other guy's tactic started jerking off
inside the sleeping bag so how much
money would it take for you to do nude
with a dude for how long how long you
have to be in there well you'd have to
if the contest is is how long it's it's
really contingent on how long he's gonna
be in there well hot what are you gonna
do to get him out of it and is he
allowed to do whatever he wants in that
bag well things can do whatever they
want it's a [ __ ] Mystics figure
payday for Ryan so yeah it's a so it
ain't gonna have I mean that's a knife
fight
you know anime my out there's got some
money wants to put up a korver million
I'll get in a sleeping bag with a dude
naked and I'll promise you don't get out
before I get out I made three hundred
and fifty dollars a week oh yeah oh yeah
but hey I was the one who coming up with
it I was like let's do noodling you know
so well the onus is on me and now we're
here we've graduated at it cups dick
cage on the way I please can we talk
about the big cage when it happens oh I
see it I want to hear all we're gonna
get the whole [ __ ] kit Mike you know
I mean I don't know how it's gonna it's
just gonna be like me going like wow I
don't know what the culmination
do get an erection it's gonna just hurt
I imagine the constraints would keep my
erection down you know I don't know it's
one of those like you're telling your
kids don't do drugs and they're gonna go
do drugs and if I'm telling myself the
whole time don't get home too hard I'm
probably gonna get hard but even with
the cameras and the lights and Tom that
made and that made you know and it's
also Christina keeps it cold in there
too yeah yeah no yeah no Christina likes
it warm but we keep it cold she does if
she has a little heater but no yeah so I
mean I feel like I won't get an erection
and it won't hurt and it'll just be you
know it'll be like when I can breeze
through well look I know we got to get
you out of here you're going down to San
Diego to do some shows first show since
the lockdown
pretty much I did I did a show for a
black lives matter benefit and lies on
Zoom but there were people it was at a
facility like at a actual venue and
there were people there so that felt
kind of like doing an open like in the
audience also yeah as well as zoom yeah
so there were like 10 people there but
so I I have that set but this is my
first time doing a substantial amount of
time in front of a live audience
all right there's people in this of
course yeah was it 50 people or 50
percent I don't know I don't know the
parameters I know that their limited
capacity yeah but it's free well I'm so
glad you came on dude thank you thank
you so much for having me of course plug
all your social media uh yeah twitter is
@j underscore potter instagram is at
josh underscore potter subscribe to my
twitch watch me play fake sports I'm
gonna buy the [ __ ] Sabre soon cuz I'm
sick of it I'm gonna be a multi I'm sick
what Terry Pegula is doing with the
Sabres I gotta save them I don't know
anything about hockey contracts but you
can watch me navigate the waters and I
guarantee I do better than [ __ ] Terry
Pegula I'm already built a dynasty with
the bills so subscribe watch all the
sports since we don't have them on
regular TV and then if you want shoulder
hair porn you can hit me up on cameo
cameo comm slash Josh underscore Potter
now tech cups are exclusively to ym age
correct we'll have requested teacups pop
they might you know what it is so
painful and it is like
those things to take them all home and
stuff they're at the studio
it's such an undertaking I've kept them
off my platform and you're dead
yeah but for you know if you have a
crazy offer I'm what okay let's talk
about it right now real quick what's the
offer
I need a G a grand and what are you what
do they get for a graph I'm giving you
five minutes you get five minutes of
tick tops they stay on I do my best I'll
put them on and off if I have to but
honest to god these [ __ ] things do it
looks like this you cannot keep them I
mean I was trying to do that bit where I
did I don't know if you saw I did that
video you know all the actors in black
and white yes I take respects Pinkman
but uh I [ __ ] did that video where I
put him on for that just to say my lines
I couldn't even keep him on to say the
lines that pain that painful I'd have to
take breaks between the lines because
they're so I don't know if I had them
well y'all heard a grand a grand for
Josh Potter to the hiccups for five
minutes
yeah and I'll do nude with a dude for
free again all right brother thank you
for coming on maybe she ate it
as always Ryan Sickler on all social
media Ryan Sickler calm we'll talk to
you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]